what is
yes
i want
oh
[Music]
so
oh
sorry
one two three four five testing one two
so
morning
beautiful
i always
so
yes
all right let's make some room here just
clear a little path for him
thank you a little bit of room sir
sir sir you move this way just a little
please make some room clear path
okay a little bit more would be great
but that's fine
good morning i'm gabriel sterling and
former chief operating officer for
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger he's in meetings right now
i am currently until over the last year
been the statewide voting system
implementation manager for the state of
georgia as we launch a new secure paper
ballot voting system
i wanted to give you a little update and
talk more about process and where we
stand right now and give some
context to the time it's taking for the
results to come out here and really
around the rest of the country
as many of y'all know it's counties who
run elections
and there are 159 counties in the state
some are more resourced than others
there are counties in the state that
have a part-time employee be the
director of their elections and it takes
time and effort to do these things and
then we have
counties have over 800 000 registered
voters and also takes time to process
those things
so as we move forward another couple
things i want to put into context for
you is
people have asked why has the number not
moved more quickly
well as you all know the law calls for
all absentee ballots to be accepted by 7
pm on election day
so obviously on election day itself
election officials are very very busy
actually running the election day voting
so normally they'll do is have to come
back in that evening and into the next
day
and accept those ballots and by
accepting them they have to go through
signature match
and all the other processes to confirm
the validity of those and in our case in
georgia
especially when they come in right
before or on election day itself
we have to get notifications out to
those people that they have three days
to come in and cure their balance
that all takes time it all takes effort
there's only so many people who are
involved in these processes in the 159
counties in this state
i know there's been questions about
numbers that move around i've heard
twenty five thousand fifty
thousand sixty thousand the reality is
it's about sixty thousand votes that are
out right now
and we're working with the counties to
make sure that they have properly put
their stuff into their system and
uploaded
as like many of y'all during this
election cycle they're tired
sometimes they're going to forget to
press the upload button so we
recently this morning done an extra
email and follow up phone calls through
our liaisons and the elections office to
make sure they have uploaded everything
bedrock upon which people will believe
the outcomes of this election
be there on the winning side or the
losing side so accuracy is
vital and it's the key to all of our
processes i want to make sure we told
everybody in this room
and in this state and around the country
this is the first time georgia has used
paper ballots in
20 years we told people do not they can
expect
some results on election night and we
got a lot of them out there
um in fact we got down to 250 000
yesterday we were down to about 60 000
today
so let me go through what we know we
have right now
i brought my computer so i wouldn't
screw it up um
bryan county 3027
burke county 494 chatham county
17 157 clayton county
7408
cobb county approximately 700
floyd county 682
forsyth county 4713
fulton county 11 200
gwinnett county 7300
harris county 3641
lawrence county 1797
putnam county 1552
taylor county 456
for a total right now of approximately
just over 60
000 votes the anticipation is we will
continue to go through the process
throughout the day
and into the evening if necessary i know
there are large counties in this state
that stayed overnight
uh fulton county being one of those to
process these and they've
knocked their numbers down to that 11
200.
we anticipate being getting through this
process today one of the
reasons that our friends in chatham
county take a little bit longer is they
have a unique system
where their border registration is
separate from their elections division
and they handle different sides of the
absentee ballot and the reporting
process so that's one of the things that
held them up but i think we're through
that process today
and i anticipate getting the majority of
the 17 000 in today as well
so with that um i want to thank y'all
for being here and answer any questions
we'll start with justin over here
can you explain to us why that number
seems to be such a moving target with
the number of absentee ballots
as i said earlier the all the ballots
have come in
by 7 pm on election day had to be logged
in
now at the same time they're making
reports on the other side
so they're drawing from the let's say
there's ten thousand ballots they report
two thousand ballots they add a thousand
ballots that means you have nine
thousand ballots
and that's why the number of potential
votes that are available will continue
to
be changing what we've essentially seen
now is that that number stopped growing
which is why we went from 250 000
yesterday about this time to 60 000
today
yes ma'am
well the main thing there's several
things that work on this system and the
biggest one of all is we have paper
ballots so there's going to be a record
of what has occurred here
as any questions you can always go back
to do an audit and a recount
um in many places everything is open to
the public we are poll watchers in these
places
in places like fulton county the state
has placed a monitor
and we've had investigators go as any
questions about how these ballots are
being handled
and move forward it's frustrating
time when everybody else is done here's
the thing florida has more to count than
we do
but their margins wider so that matter
is much we have a much smaller margin
and we're aware of that fact
and the county elections officials feel
that pressure they understand
they are working hard my hats are off to
them having to go through this process
and be under this level of scrutiny
they're all doing
extremely well and i
these are 159 elections directors and
employees
who are here to do the job of protecting
democracy
when you go to talk to them they think
about that they think about the votes of
every person
in this room and around the country
these are people are not involved
in voter fraud these people are not
involved in voter suppression
i'm telling you they're doing their jobs
every day
it is hard and we are thankful to them
for it and we're going to work with them
to make sure that every
legal lawful ballot is counted
i'm risk limiting audience can you tell
us the criteria for
the decision that would be made at what
race to look at and
has that decision the decision hasn't
been made yet
uh the exact criteria have to as defined
in the state election board rule
um it'll be it'll be decided um
probably after we get the county
certification or not long before
uh the secretary is the one who solely
gets to make that decision so i won't
speak for him here
uh sir i just said you look at the seb
rules and that outlines the definition
i'm not going to be able to answer that
yes sir
what do you want to call chad
it's it's a lawsuit to be handled at the
county level as i understand it
it may only affect 50 ballots but i'm
sure that their legal counsel will give
them the advice they need to get through
the process mr fowler
hold on one second i can't hear anything
with that whatever they're doing up
there
[Music]
we are working with the counties to try
to get a full understanding of how many
provisionals might be available
um mr fowler who's done a good job
reporting on this election
uh makes a very good point that the
election is not over
just on the absentee ballots there are
absentee ballots from our overseas
military voters that if they are
postmarked by tuesday
have to be accepted by friday there are
provisional ballots that need to be
verified by friday and if you have an
absentee ballot with an issue like
missing a signature or something you
have until friday to cure those
yes ma'am
that's why literally for the last two
months we have said it will be you know
wednesday or thursday before we knew the
answer to this so yes
the secretary of state's office received
any reports
um any report we get of any kind of
regularity our investigative division
will look into and ascertain the
validity of that report and if necessary
investigate
yes
for sir particular election i can't say
for certain right now i knew we have
reports around several things i'm not
sure about voter fraud or anything
because that's kind of a broad term so
i'll be more specific
and question and we'll get with our
investigations division try to get a
specific answer to that
yes sir
nothing because i'm not heard of
anything about a corrupt scanner in
gwinnett county
uh i i have no information about that
yes sir
as i said in the beginning of this thing
there's a possibility that some counties
might not have had upload yet this
possibility
that they could have not had a random
one here there so
but as far as the general outlines of
these we anticipate that the absentee
ballots that are there are there
and we have the extra bit of security
that we know the number of requests
therefore we know that is the most
outlying ability of anything to be done
so we know the outer limits of anything
possible but right now as we say here
today
yes we feel comfortable that number yeah
just what about the possibility of a
recount
georgia law provides for that for the
candidates and it looks like the
presidential race we're moving into that
margin uh there is a possibility of that
occurring uh georgia law calls for fewer
than a half
of the certified results then the losing
candidate or i guess the winning
candidate if they wanted to
could call for a recount and that would
be a statewide recount conducted one of
the things that we did in procuring our
new dominion voting system
is we provided for the knowing the
state's
general political situations after 2018
we provided high-capacity scanners to
every single county in the state
so that they could conduct a statewide
recount if it became necessary
well mark if you weren't late you would
heard the answer to that already
no that wouldn't be possible the
judication process gets us to the final
number to certify
state law requires that the county
certify their results 10 day from the
election and then we have some time
after that we hope to do it faster than
that because
we need to be able to do when the county
is certified we're then going to move
into the risk limiting audit phase
and then after this on the audit is
closed out then we will certify the
election
yes ma'am
as i said in the press conference on
election day we are focusing on getting
the
election itself done um we do believe it
was a data set issue
don't know exactly why yet but we have
uh our vendor
we're working on it but right now we are
really focused on making sure we get the
uh
answers out yes ma'am
i can't speak to what investigations
have been opened yet i know there's some
discussions about that we'll
have to give you after that after
talking to our chief of investigations
hey good to see you a new
approximation for deadline and today you
said it just like
today is possible so end of day today
maybe
i am prayerful that we can get to a
resolution by the end of the day but as
has been pointed out by everybody
this is going to be an extremely close
margin especially in the presidential
election
and we anticipate every one of those yu
akava
incurable ballots and and provisionals
may come into account in that so
having a final one it may it may take a
minute stephen
probably not but i can give it a shot
the adjudication process is a new system
here in georgia
under the old system of scanning when
you've had handmark paper ballots
which are something that unfortunately
as a hammer paper ballot
is very open to human frailty and
mistakes um
we can use an electronic communication
system where it takes a picture of those
ballots
and the computer used to just say if
it's an overvote we're gonna kick it out
which means there's two
ovals marked for a single race we're
gonna kick it out and then a human being
will get a chance to look at it
under the new system it will also look
at overvotes plus it will look at
anything like an ambiguous mark
so if somebody has a check mark or
anything like that it brings it up onto
a screen
and a bipartisan panel will then examine
that ballot
to discern the voter intent then it is
marked in the system
and it can be counted properly yes sir
you'd have to be more specific we don't
toss out ballots in the states
yes we wouldn't have a tracking on that
right now because that's basically
if you you've mismarked something that
is not a actual vote cast in that race
and just because there's a mistake on
one part of your battle doesn't mean the
rest of your ballot would still get
counted yes
is that sorry okay i'm gonna yeah
that kind of made my skin crawl when
when he's saying that
130 000 ballots have been scanned in
batches and they've adjudicated
the small percentage of those inside
this hundred and thirty thousand so to
give some clarity to that
yes next month
tomorrow well as i said we have to
accept those until friday we can't know
what's going to get here until the time
actually gets here for that don't tell
me i punched you all out
all right with that i just want to say
one more thank you to the voters in the
state of georgia
the secretary begs your patience this is
a
long process but i think all of us would
agree that having
accurate count is much more vital an
accurate and fair account is much more
vital
than having a fast so thank you and
we'll try to follow up with any other
questions for later today you have a
great
thank
day
you